[Music]  why does your elbow hurt so much when  you bump it the wrong way  it's called whacking your funny bone  but that awkward tingling sensation has  nothing to do with the bone you're  actually assaulting a nerve in your  elbow it's called the ulnar nerve it  extends from your spine to the pinky and  ring fingers but along the way it passes  across the elbow there's no muscle  around this joint to protect it and it's  the largest unprotected nerve in your  body so when you bump your elbow you  actually compress the nerve this  temporarily hinders your nerves  connection to the brain and the result  is a numbing sensation of pins and  needles which shoots up and down your  entire arm the same phenomenon happens  when your foot falls asleep the  sensation is temporary and shouldn't  cause permanent damage if it lasts  longer than a few minutes this could be  a sign of the medical condition cubital  tunnel syndrome and you should consult a  physician immediately  [Music]